los refugiados también se movilizan por
América Latina en el marco del día para
conmemorar el desplazamiento en el mundo
un grupo de organizaciones civiles y más
de 400 solicitantes de Refugio salieron
a las calles de Tapachula al sur de
México para visibilizar su condición
migratoria un encuentro Sin fronteras
como se denominó la protesta tuvo lugar
cuando se reporta una cifra récord de
solicitudes de asilo de personas
desplazadas principalmente desde
Centroamérica son más de
250 kilómetros en México
eso implica Pues sí hay mucha presión
Porque el 70% de las solicitudes
prácticamente se hace aquí en Tapachula
y en Palenque por ejemplo México es país
de tránsito y destino para miles de
personas que huyen de la violencia la
represión política y la inestabilidad
económica que azota países como Honduras
Guatemala El Salvador y Nicaragua sobre
este último el colectivo nunca más ong
nicaragüense encargada de documentar
violaciones a los derechos humanos en el
país centroamericano informó que desde
las protestas contra el presidente
Daniel Ortega en abril de 2018 el país
ha experimentado El Éxodo humano más
grande de su historia
[Música]
entre abril de 2018 y diciembre de 2022
al menos
462.810 personas nicaragüenses se habían
desplazado forzadamente fuera del país y
en su mayoría solicitaron formalmente
alguna categoría de protección
internacional en Estados Unidos Costa
Rica México y España
a junio de 2023 serían más de 600.000
los que salieron de Nicaragua en busca
de protección según Naciones Unidas
existen unos 20 millones de desplazados
en América Latina una condición
invisibilizada en la región pero que hoy
se encuentra más latente que nunca